we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i've
mentioned this before that there are
people who call in and say there will
never be self-driving cars even though
we have them and that we will never go
to mars even though i believe we are
going to mars one of those people that
used to call in all the time and say
david there will never be self-driving
cars is troy york and he called in and
he said david we are never going to mars
take a listen
go to Pakman we are not going to mars we
are not going to mars we can't even
settle the moon
we can't even settle the moon the idea
of mars is a scam for the technocrats to
get monetary resources diverted towards
their companies hire their engineers
give them exorbitant salaries and you
know it Jack Jones knows it and Scott
Horton knows it so basically I don't
know I don't know there is no money
hello
yeah there is little Helen they can be
devoted for faith ventures to Mars yeah
okay this is the same guy who for years
said there will never be self-driving
cars he's not making those phone calls
anymore it may be by we he doesn't mean
humankind he talks about you and him
personally
right Froy York and I are not going to
be the first person to go to Mars that's
the only group that's the only way to
understand his voicemail that might make
it a reality at some point so anyway
these people exist they will continue to
exist and we'll talk more about them on
the bonus show which you can access by
becoming a member at david pakman.com
slash membership or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show